just when we thought Spiderman was going
to be the new face of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe for years to come
a standoff between Disney and Sony could
put a stop to it
so what does this mean for the future of
the MCU and spider-man let's discuss
right now on to catch up I can't believe
I'm saying this but after failed
negotiations Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige will not be involved in the
next two planned spider-man movies and
the character whose film rights are held
by Sony Pictures will no longer be
available to Marvel Studios this isn't
the Daily Bugle guys this is happening
and it's wild I'm Sam as far as what
this means for the MCU well all that
talk about spider-man being the next
Iron Man and far from home Plus Nick
Fury wanting him to help out up in space
means he was going to be a major player
in phase five or six so this is gonna be
a tough web for them to untangle and
this whole time I thought spider-man go
see Nick Fury was a joke you do not go
sniff fury let's talk about the future
of spider-man since having your own
cinematic universe is totally a thing
now Sony is planning to expand upon the
spider verse which has about 900
characters to choose from that's a lot
of characters and coming off the heels
of 2018 certified fresh' oscar-winning
animated movie spider-man into the
spider-verse
Sony also has a sequel to venom starring
Tom Hardy coming next year and projects
for characters like Kraven the hunter
silver sable and black hat are also in
development plus a movie with Morbius
the living vampire played by Jared Leto
is also coming in 2021
as for the upcoming spider-man movies
even with Tom Holland and director John
watts returning it might get kind of
weird not being able to reference things
like Peters journey with MCU his
connections to Stark Industries not to
mention the motivation behind Jake
Gyllenhaal's Mysterio and on top of all
of that there's poor Tom Holland stuck
in the middle of all of this and I think
we all know how he feels about playing
spider-man because well he told me he
would play spider-man until like I can't
walk anymore
basically this all comes down to money
Disney who owns Marvel wants to do an
even split of all future spider-man
films but Sony said no and wants to keep
the current deal where it stands
which means Marvel gets a small
percentage of the gross in other words
they just don't want to share their big
franchise and this is despite the fact
that the Feige produced spider-man far
from home film recently became Sony's
highest-grossing movie ever and maybe
that's just it
looking to the near future Marvel's face
war films slated for the next couple
years actually don't have much to do
with Spidey the upcoming sequel Doctor
Strange and the multiverse badness will
most likely take place far from
Manhattan where Peter was just revealed
and blamed for everything
so I guess he'll just be in hiding till
he can clear his name I mean literally
and that could mean shang-chi with the
movie coming in 2021 we'll take a more
central role in the MCU and Sony is
definitely feeling the heat and
shouldering most of the blame on social
media so they put out a series of tweets
saying quote much of today's news about
spider-man has mischaracterized recent
discussions about Kevin Feige Zin vault
mint and the franchise we are
disappointed but respect is these
decision not to have him continue as a
lead producer of our next live-action
spider-man film Kevin is terrific and we
are grateful for his help and guidance
and appreciate the pakis helped put us
on which we will continue but whether
it's Disney or Sony that's to blame it
doesn't really matter because it's the
fans who are losing right I mean even
Hawkeye himself Jeremy Renner is hoping
this gets resolved by staying on
Instagram
hey Sony Pictures we want spider-man
back to Stanley and Marvel please thank
you
who knows guys maybe we'll get some
answers soon seeing as Disney's d23
expose this weekend come on man please
but it's time to kick it over to you now
because I have a lot of questions what
do you think about an MCU without
spider-man and spider-man without the
MCU
are you hashtag save spider-man or are
you excited to see what the Sony
spider-verse has to offer or are you
just waiting for the next DC movie and
did Iron Man die for nothing
let Hitz know in the comments section
all your feelings and if you liked this
episode and want to see more hit that
subscribe button and click that Bell
icon to be notified of all future
episodes
as always I'm Matt Perez and I'm going
to send all my therapy bills to Sony and
dizzy now
[Music]